Es war nicht zu prüfen, eine Showung für den Kräuterein zu machen. Das sah nicht so gut aus, aber dann hat jemand als ein wissenschaftlicher Amerikaner die Beweise, den Effizienz der Lokomotion für einen Mann auf einem Bicyclet zu testen. Und ein Mann auf einem Bicyclet, ein Mensch auf einem Bicyclet, hat den Condor komplett aus den Schichten ausgeruht.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 69. Mein Name wie immer Tim Pritlove und wir schreiben den 19. Januar 2008 und auf meiner Podcast-Reise hat mich mein Weg mittlerweile ins schöne München geführt, weil München ja eine total interessante Stadt ist. Vor allem ist hier immer so viel, also aus Gründen, die ich mir noch nicht so ganz erklären kann, sind hier so unheimlich viele Computerfirmen angesiedelt. Eine davon ist die Firma Apple, die ja immer schwer in der Diskussion ist und so soll es auch heute mal bei Chaosradio Express sein. Diese Sendung und voraussichtlich auch die nächste Sendung hint hint wird sich um den Mac drehen mit unterschiedlichen Aspekten, um die Büchse mal ein bisschen zu beleuchten, da sie für viele Leute so eine kleine Blackbox darstellt und es vor allem auch eine ganze Menge Mythen und Meinungen, die nicht unbedingt stimmen, im Raum fliegen. Und ja, jemand, der sich dieser Mythenbildung ein wenig angenommen hat, ist Lucy und die ist jetzt auch hier mit dabei. Hallo Lucy. Du hast ja einen Vortrag gehalten auf dem 24C3 in diesem Jahr, genau zu diesem Thema, richtig? Ich war dabei und ich fand das super. Das war ja auch dein erster Kongress, stimmt's?
Das war mein erster Kongress.
Und wie war's?
Es war sehr interessant. Vor allem die anderen Vorträge haben mich sehr bereichert, muss ich echt sagen.
Hast du viel Zeit mit Vorträgen verbracht?
Einigermaßen, würde ich sagen, ja, doch. Also so im Vergleich zu anderen, die sich dann eher im Keller aufhalten, dann doch sehr viel Zeit.
Ja, das stimmt. Manche kommen überhaupt nicht raus aus dem Hacksetter. Aber du warst umtriebig und hast ja irgendwie dieses und jenes angeschaut. Irgendwas, was dir da besonders gefallen hat?
Ja, ich habe mich schon immer für Thor interessiert. Und das war ein sehr interessanter Vortrag.
Von Roger Dingeldein? Dem Schreiber von Thor, genau. Ja, der weiß natürlich eine Menge darüber. Und der gibt ja eigentlich auch in der Regel jedes Jahr ein Update. Und der Club ist auch selber sehr aktiv mit Thor-Servern am Werkeln. Hast du auch Thor selber im Einsatz?
Noch nicht, aber ich habe schon eine Visitenkarte bekommen. Genau, um das dann auch wieder in die Wege zu leiten. Momentan.
Und so der Kongress an sich, wie hat dir das gefallen? Was war so dein Eindruck?
Ich fand es sehr spannend, dass doch unterschiedlichste Typen von Hackern, sage ich jetzt mal, zu Gange waren. Es sind teilweise nur Menschen, die einfach nur mal so ein bisschen reinschnuppern wollten, sich für Computers so interessieren, die anderen, die einfach was basteln wollen und sich mit anderen treffen wollen, andere, die was lernen wollen. Das war ein sehr gemischtes Bild und das hat mich echt fasziniert.
Also bist du wieder dabei im nächsten Jahr?
Ich würde sagen schon.
Das ist super. Ja, zu deinem Vortrag. Du hast dich dem Mac OS X Kernel angenommen. Was war deine Motivation, das Thema aufzurufen?
Meine Motivation war in erster Linie, eben diese ganzen merkwürdigen Wörter, die da so im Geiste viele rumschwirren, mal ein bisschen aufzuräumen. Es ist ja doch so, dass der typische Mac-User jemand ist, der einen Computer haben will, der einfach funktioniert. Und da würde ich sagen, da gibt es zwei Gruppen. Die einen, die überhaupt nichts damit zu tun haben wollen, die einfach einschalten und dann klicken sie wieder drauf. Für die ist der Vortrag dann vermutlich wieder nichts, weil sie überhaupt nicht wissen wollen, was ein Kernel in dem Fall jetzt überhaupt ist.
Aber die sind ja auch nicht so vertreten auf dem Kongress.
Das auch. Gut, die andere Gruppe, die sie einfach nur benutzen wollen, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, sind die, die vielleicht den einen oder anderen mit C zu Hause stehen haben, der nicht immer funktioniert, weil er ein Victim ist oder ähnliches.
Ein was ist?
Ein Victim.
Ach so, ein Opfer.
Und die eigentlich schon am Programmieren sind und sich da ein bisschen dafür interessieren, was innerhalb dieses Computers passiert, aber den Mac trotzdem dafür haben, dafür einen Rechner zu haben, der immer funktioniert, der ein UNIX-Rechner ist und auf den man sich jeden verlassen kann.
Hast du auch selber einen Mac?
Ich habe mehrere Macs.
Mehrere Macs? Was sind die?
Ja, einen Server, einen Mac Mini, einen zuverlässiger Server und natürlich ein iBook.
Fährt der Mac Mini dann auch Mac OS X Server?
Nein.
Das heißt, ja, das ist ja schon mal eine entscheidende Frage. Es gibt ja zwei Varianten von Mac OS X, eben Mac OS X, die normale, kleine Version, über die die meisten eigentlich immer reden und schreiben, und die Server-Variante. Ich muss sagen, ich habe die letzten auch nicht ausprobiert, aber ich habe mit dem, seit 10.3 Mac OS X Server, was heißt seit, also bis 10.3 habe ich damit gearbeitet und fand das eigentlich immer ganz fancy, weil das so ein Server ist, wo man eine ganze Menge an sehr komplexen Services relativ einfach an den Start kriegt. Es fehlt einem natürlich dann ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt auch so diese unlimited configurability, die man jetzt so mit so einem selbst aufgesetzten BSD oder Linux einfacher hat. Aber die Standard-Services wiederum sind sehr leicht hinzukriegen, was weiß ich, so mal eben Mating-Listen aufsetzen und so. Das ist ja eigentlich kein einfacher Task. Und ja, auch da zeigt halt, dass Apple so einen Ansatz hat, mit dem so, naja, wir kümmern uns drum. Und das ist ja auch mal etwas, was immer extrem in der Kritik steht bei vielen. Gerade bei den Hardcore-UNIX-Anwendern, die ja auch UNIX deshalb benutzen, weil sie eben dann auch lieber den Schraubenzieher in der Hand haben und irgendwie an allen selber drehen. So nach dem Motto, was ich selber eingestellt habe, da weiß man, was man hat. Nur, das heißt eben auch, das muss man eben auch erstmal können. Und von daher gibt es dann auch immer so unterschiedliche Ansichten darüber, was jetzt der Mac OS X Kernel leisten kann oder nicht. Vielleicht nochmal, bevor wir da jetzt wirklich drauf eingehen, ein bisschen so zu deinem Hintergrund. Wie bist du jetzt überhaupt dahingekommen, das so zu adressieren? Was ist da so deine Erfahrung und dein Interesse? Computertechnisch generell. Also was auch immer dich jetzt da hingebracht hat. Also mit Rechnern vermute ich mal, bist du schon eine Weile zu Gange?
Ja, durchaus nicht so lange. Früher gab es so einen Heimcomputer, das war dann ein Windows-Rechner noch. Und dann bin ich in meiner schon späteren Jugend eigentlich mit einem Linux-Rechner allein gelassen worden.
Allein im Zimmer eingeschlossen.
Nein, das war so ein Halbfertiger, der mir einen Freund so hingestellt hat und gesagt hat, ja, das geht schon, guck, das ist genau wie Windows, das geht schon und dann hat aber nichts funktioniert. Wie man das vielleicht so sprichwörtlich kennt bei Linux, da ist mir nichts funktioniert. Aber ich habe mir dann eben nicht gedacht, so geht das nicht, sondern mir gedacht, was passiert hier eigentlich und warum geht es nicht? So und dann knapp ein Jahr später hat das alles funktioniert und ich wusste im Wesentlichen auch warum. Und so bin ich erstmal zu Linux gekommen. Und dann habe ich genau aus dem genannten Grund irgendwann mir ein iBook gekauft, weil es ein netter Computer war, der immer tragbar war, immer dabei war und habe festgestellt, mit dem kann man auch gut leben. Das ist auch interessant und nachdem ich mich schon immer eigentlich auch bei Linux in erster Linie für einen Kernel interessiert habe, habe ich mir auch den Mac OS Kernel mal angeschaut. Was aber dann im Wesentlichen initialisiert wurde durch Amit Singh, den ich kennenlernen durfte und der mir dann sein Buch gegeben hat.
Er war auch im 23C3, ein Vortrag leider nicht über den Mac OS X Kernel, sondern der war bei uns auf dem Kongress, also nicht mit dem 23C3, sondern im Jahr davor und hat einen Vortrag gehalten über diesen Mythos, auch wieder so ein Mythos, dass die Macintoshes trusted computing unterstützen, was er ja durch so ein Paper relativ klar hat ausräumen können, weil seine Feststellung war halt einerseits, was eben viele Leute nicht wussten, dass bei den ersten Intel Macs tatsächlich diesen Chip hatten, dass er aber nicht benutzt wurde, also lag schlicht kein Treiber vor in dem Betriebssystem, der den auch nur in irgendeiner Form anspricht und schon zu dem Zeitpunkt des Vortrags war es halt so, dass die zweite Generation der Intel Macs draußen war, die den Chip noch nicht mal mehr hatten. Also das Thema hat sich dann noch relativ schnell erledigt. Das heißt, du hast auch wahrscheinlich sein Buch gelesen, diese dicke Schwarte.
Naja, nicht ganz, also das hat man doch wirklich ins Detail gelesen.
Es ist wirklich ein verdammt dickes Buch und auch ich habe es nicht zu Ende gelesen, aber vor allem, weil ich noch nicht dazu gekommen bin, es zu Ende zu lesen, ich werde es definitiv noch tun, weil ich liebe auch sowas, so Kernel-Material. Das hat ja auch eine gewisse Tradition im UNIX-Bereich, es gab eigentlich mit der einzigen Ausnahme von Linux, soweit ich weiß, lieber Hörer, ihr dürft mich korrigieren, aber es ist so, dass UR-UNIX hatte so seinen Klassiker, das war The Design of the UNIX Operating System von Maurice Bach, das war halt auch so eine Fiebel, damals glaube ich bei Prentice Hall erschienen, wo halt so einmal so von vorne bis hinten und das ist der Kernel. Das ist das, was UNIX tatsächlich macht, so ist das Fallsystem aufgebaut, so läuft das mit den Prozessen, so läuft das mit der Interprozessenkommunikation, lalalalalala. Im BSD-Lager gibt es das Teufelchenbuch von, oh Gott, jetzt komme ich ins Schwimmen, die vier Autoren.
Für Microsoft gibt es Windows NT Internals, ich weiß auch gar nicht von wem.
Da bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, ob es wirklich auch so den selben Aspekt abdeckt.
Das gibt es, das liegt bei mir zu Hause.
Ist das so? Und beschreibt das auch dieselbe Tiefe? Weil ich habe sowas nämlich mal für Windows NT gesucht, da gab es das nicht.
Das ist eigentlich ganz brauchbar und entspricht so im Wesentlichen an mit dem Buch.
Ah, okay, gut. Bei Linux ist mir so ein Buch nicht bekannt. Ich meine, es gibt natürlich zahlreiche Bücher über Linux. Aber so richtig so eine Autorität wie Linus Torvalds, die einfach mal sich hingesetzt hätte und gesagt hat, so Linux, der Kernel und so weiter und jetzt immer die ganze Geschichte und ich erkläre mal von vorne bis hinten, wie das ist, gibt es meiner Meinung nach nicht. Vielleicht habe ich sie aber nur noch nicht gefunden und weiß zu wenig. Tatsache ist, dass dieses Buch von Amit Singh so ein bisschen auf dem Weg ist, diese Rolle einzunehmen. Also wirklich so die Referenz zu sein. Er ist ja selber nicht bei Apple, sondern bei Google interessanterweise und dort für die Macintosh-Entwicklung zuständig. Da habe ich allerdings noch einiges dran, um auszusetzen. Aber darum soll es jetzt nicht gehen. Sondern wir wollen mal so ein bisschen die Geschichte von Mac OS X auch aufarbeiten. Du hast das ja in deinem Vortrag schon sehr elegant gemacht. Wir wollen jetzt hier auch nicht den Vortrag wiederholen, sondern vielleicht auch an dieser Stelle mal darauf direkt verweisen. Es gibt auch ein paar Chaosradio im Übrigen. Es gibt ein 24C3-Podcast, wo auch die Aufzeichnung dieses Vortrages zu finden ist. Und du hast ja dann relativ didaktisch auch sozusagen die Kernaspekte dargelegt. Aber vielleicht fangen wir mal so ein bisschen da an, wo es Mac OS X noch gar nicht gab. Apple ist ja nun jahrelang mit Mac OS gefahren. Ein Betriebssystem, das sich im Wesentlichen durch sein User-Interface ausgezeichnet hat, aber weniger durch seinen Kernel.
Ja, damals hieß es ja noch gar nicht Mac OS. Damals hieß es noch System 7, System 8.
Richtig. Oh ja.
Mac OS 9 dann erst.
Hast du damit eigentlich auch mal gearbeitet?
Mac OS 9, aber davor nichts.
Und wie war das? Also wenn ich heute so zurückdenke, ist es ein bisschen gruselig.
Es ist nett, hübsch. Man sieht schon die Grundzüge, oder zumindest die Zielgruppe sieht man schon.
Was ist deine Meinung nach, die Zielgruppe?
Diejenigen, die ein schönes Bild haben wollen und die wollen, dass es harmonisch funktioniert und dass sie sich nicht um was es sich Treiber kümmern müssen, um Hardware-Komponenten und...
Ein Computer, der funktioniert?
Genau, ein Komplettpaket. Ein hübsches Paket.
Ja, das hat sich an dem Sinne nicht geändert. Allerdings hat Mac OS X ja geschafft, ganz neue Gruppen heranzuziehen. Das haben wir auch beim Kongress gesehen. 35 Prozent aller Computer, die auf dem Netzwerk gesehen wurden, waren Macs. Das spricht schon eine deutliche Sprache. Aber was... Ja, wo setzen wir da jetzt mal an? Also vielleicht springen wir doch direkt auf den Mac OS X Kernel, was er denn eigentlich ist. Also was ist Mac OS X? Der Mac OS X Kernelschüler.
Der Mac OS X Kernel.
Kann man sagen, was ist Darwin?
Darwin ist prinzipiell der Kernel. Und dann Textmode UserLand. Und die drei Beine im Wesentlichen. Also quasi alles, was jetzt nicht die grafische Oberfläche ist.
Das ist Darwin.
Und das ist auch Open Source.
Weitgehend, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Ist nicht alles wirklich vollständig veröffentlicht. Ich glaube, mit der Ausnahme, der klassischen Ausnahme der Grafiktreiber?
Ja, und ich denke auch, dass es nicht alles ist. Auch alles, was... Man kann es zu einem laufenden System kompilieren. Aber ich denke nicht, dass das, was dabei rauskommt, dann das gleiche ist. Also es wird schon noch ein bisschen mehr dahinter schieben.
Aber es gibt schon Leute, die eigene Kernels rausbringen.
Ja, eben.
Also noch zu PowerPC-Zeiten gab es das. Ich habe jetzt noch nicht beobachtet, dass jemand einen Intel XNU gemacht hat. Also XNU. Damit werden wir vielleicht mal einsteigen. Das ist ja der eigentliche Name des Kernels.
X ist not UNIX. Und das sagt eigentlich schon alles. Aber mittlerweile sind sie es wieder. Das heißt, sie sind wieder POSIX-konform. Und haben es wieder geschafft, sich UNIX nennen zu dürfen. Aber erst Leopard.
Seit 10.5. Ja, POSIX ist ja der Standard, der im Prinzip sagt, wenn du dich so verhältst, wie hier beschrieben, dann bist du ein UNIX.
Genau, ist aber eigentlich nur eine Formalität, würde ich jetzt mal sagen.
Ja, aber nicht ganz unerheblich, weil es gibt ja gerade in den USA eine ganze Menge Vorschriften, so im Government-Bereich, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Wo drin steht, wenn du hier diesen Kontrakt haben willst, und wenn diese Systeme an der und der Stelle zum Einsatz kommen sollen, dann müssen die den POSIX-Stempel haben.
Richtig.
Und ich glaube, das war dann auch die wesentliche Motivation.
Richtig, dass wir das haben wollten, um da eben mitmischen zu können.
Und woraus besteht XNU?
XNU, das sind jetzt einige Teile, nämlich Mach, dann das IOW-Kit, und jetzt bin ich gerade... BSD, natürlich. Und dann noch die LIPS-System, aber das würde ich jetzt mal außen vor lassen, LIPC, die ich ja immer geben muss.
Aber die trennst du davon noch?
Ah, Entschuldigung, Lipkern, habe ich gemeint.
Was?
Das ist nur ein kleiner Teil, der dann Kompatibilität gewährt. Da weiß ich jetzt auch nicht so genau.
Okay, aber im Kern gibt es diese drei...
Diese drei großen Komponenten.
Genau.
Mach. Genau, und das bedeutet auch schon, es gibt ja dieses Gerücht, dass der Kernel Mach wäre. Mach ist nicht der Kernel. Mach ist diese eigentliche monolithische Kernel. Der kommt von CMU, von der Carnegie Mellon University. Das ist eigentlich dieses Projekt des Micro-Kernels, der aber dann wieder nicht funktioniert hat, weil es einfach doch etwas zu langsam war, weil man die ganze Zeit Address-Space switchen musste, und das dauert einfach.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen der Informatik-Hype der 80er-Jahre gewesen, dass man gesagt hat, große, schwere, massive Körner, das kann ja nicht gut gehen, weil da hängt dann zu viel voneinander ab, das ist alles zu schlecht strukturiert, und wir müssen ja auch über mehr Prozessorsysteme nachdenken, wir wollen ja Verteilzeit usw. Und dann gab es so verschiedenste Vorstöße in diese Microkernel-Welt, da war ja Mach nur einer davon. Das ist ja auch im Prinzip so diese mythische Geburtsstunde von Linux, wo ja der Andrew Tannenbaum mit seinem Minix groß rumgepost hat, und überhaupt generell diese akademische Sicht von Microkernel sind gut, weil sie sehen auf dem Papier besser ausgebracht hat, während Linus Torwald gesagt hat, scheiß drauf, ich hacke das jetzt hier alles mal in einen Kernel, und wer macht halt recht und wer am Schluss den laufenden Kot hat, gewinnt. Und das hat er ja auch gewonnen. Oh, wir hören Geräusche. Wir ignorieren das. So, und Mach ist dieses andere Projekt, was ja auch sehr ambitioniert angegangen wurde, was dann so zahlreiche Auswüchse gehabt hat, was dann bei der USF auch gelandet ist. Eine dieser Foundations, die sich dann sozusagen um die Zukunft von UNIX kümmern haben. Das war ja auch so das Memen in den 80er Jahren. Ja, UNIX und so, wir haben ganz viele davon. Aber eines Tages werden wir das goldene UNIX haben, das Uber-UNIX, was irgendwie alle vereinigt, wo Sun und Solaris und AT&T und alle diese ganzen Player, die auf dem Markt waren, alle in Happy Wonderland über die Wiese springen werden und man ist sich endlich einig. Dazu ist es nie gekommen. Und vor allem haben auch diese Microkernel sich nicht durchgesetzt. Das hast du ja schon erwähnt. Vielleicht können wir noch mal darauf eingehen. Was ist das Problem eines Microkernels?
Das Problem eines Microkernels ist, dass wenn der Kernel jetzt in den Address-Space, wenn der Address-Space vom Kernel auf den Arbeitsspeicher gelinkt ist, aber eine User-Land-Application zum Zuge kommen will, muss es geswitcht werden.
Weil es halt eine Trennung geben muss zwischen dem... Richtig. Also User-Land ist sozusagen die Programme, die Applikation, die man fährt. Genau, was im User-Mode läuft im Vergleich zum Kernel, der halt im Kernel-Mode läuft. Und der Address-Space muss geswitcht werden. Das heißt, die Sichtweise auf den Speicher, den das Programm hat, die Sichtweise, den der Kernel hat.
Genau, beide haben das Gefühl, sowohl der Kernel als auch die Applikation haben beide das Gefühl, sie hätten den ganzen Addressraum. Und das wird ja gemapt. Und in dem Moment, wo entweder Kernel oder die Applikation diesen Addressraum haben wollen, für sich beanspruchen wollen, muss eben immer diese Pagetable geswitcht werden. Und das dauert jedes Mal.
Das kostet Zeit. Das muss beim Micro-Kernel halt häufiger gemacht werden, weil der Micro-Kernel, wie der Name schon so schön sagt, sich ja um weniger kümmert. Worum kümmert sich der Micro-Kernel?
Der macht im Endeffekt nur im Fall von Mach, nur in der Process Communication, dann ganz tatsächlich das Low-Level-Hardware-Management und Scheduling natürlich zwischen den Prozessen.
Das heißt, er verwaltet Speicher, er verwaltet Zeit und er verwaltet die Kommunikation zwischen den Prozessen. Genau. Und das ist ja nicht alles. Man braucht Datalsysteme, Visos und jenes und all diese ganzen Dienstleistungen, die man heutzutage so gewohnt ist von einem Kernel.
Genau, das macht dann in dem Fall der BSD-Server. Das ist jetzt nicht der komplette BSD-Kernel, sondern man hat eben das, was Mach schon macht, die Teile rausgenommen, diese Hardware-Management, IPC und Scheduling und so weiter. Das hat man rausgenommen aus dem BSD-Teil und quasi nur noch die Teile verwendet vom BSD-Kern, die Mach eben nicht abdeckt. Und damit eben zum Beispiel die POSIX-Conformance erreicht. Dann gibt es im Market nur Tasks, das heißt, die haben kein Working Directory, wie man es ja kennt von Linux. Das wird durch BSD wieder erweitert, sodass es neben Runtime-Environments richtig ist und ein Working Directory und all die Aspekte.
Wir sollten vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen die Sachen in den Kontext rutschen. Also BSD, Berkeley Software Distribution, das ist ja eigentlich UNIX. Das UR UNIX, was bei SLT&T geboren wurde, lebt heutzutage in Form von BSD UNIX fort. Das ist ja eigentlich der große Nachfolger. Und die BSD-Geschichten, also Free BSD, Open BSD, Net BSD, so als die drei populärsten Varianten. Es gibt noch ein paar kleinere Entwicklungen. Das haben wir neulich schon bei Chaosradio Express als ein Free BSD erläutert. Das ist ja eigentlich so das, was den Großteil des UNIX-Codes auch wirklich neu geschrieben hat. Also, dass die Copyright-Ansprüche von AT&T dann auch nicht mehr greifen. Und die einzigen, die jetzt eigentlich noch aus dieser Vergangenheit sozusagen Code benutzen, sind Sun mit Solaris. Sun ist ja auch irgendwann mal umgestiegen auf UNIX-System 5. Und das sind eigentlich so diese Systeme, die sozusagen diesen Wir-sind-das-Ur-UNIX haben, während ja Linux eine komplett neue Entwicklung ist. Heutzutage nimmt man ja so, wenn man von UNIX spricht, so Linux eigentlich primär war. Aber Linux ist ja eigentlich eine komplette neue Implementierung, die mit der Urentwicklung nichts zu tun hat. Wie auch immer, BSD ist auch wie Linux ein monolithischer Kernel, wo also alles in einem ist, wo man sich eben, um die Sachen, die wir gerade gestellt haben, worum sich Mac kümmert, also worum sich ein Mac-Kernel kümmert, plus alles andere in einer Suppe war. Das heißt, was Apple jetzt gemacht hat, bzw. man muss ja sagen, was Nextstep seinerzeit gemacht hat.
Das war damals Nextstep, ja. Und es wurde auch dann, nachdem Nextstep bzw. dieses Operating-System von Apple gekauft wurde, wurden auch Teile wieder ersetzt. Also nicht direkt diese Version von Mac, die Nextstep verwendet hat, sondern als sie Mac OS schreiben wollten, haben sie dann Mac abgegradet und BSD auch von, ich glaube, 4.4 war das dann.
Die neueste Version von Mac genommen, die neueste Version von verfügbaren BSD-Sources. Ich glaube, die haben sich im Wesentlichen wohl bei FreeBSD bedient, aber es war ja schon immer so, dass der BSD-Kernel eben der auf Mac angepasst ist. Und das hast du ja vorhin schon gesagt. Das heißt, man hat das, worum sich Mac kümmert.
Also die Teile, die von Mac bereits erledigt werden, die Hardware-Management und IPC und so weiter, die wurden dann aus dem BSD-Kernel rausgenommen und durch die Mac-Teile ersetzt, durch den Mac-Code ersetzt. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt eine schöne Trennung. Das ist eigentlich ganz praktisch. Und es können BSD-Applications eben dann auch verwendet werden.
Genau, weil letzten Endes ist ja der Gesamtkernel auch nach wie vor mit dem BSD-UNIX-Interface ausgestattet. Und deswegen hat ja Mac OS X eigentlich auch so viele Gesichter. Es gibt halt so den UNIX-Layer, das ist ein normaler User-Layer. Deswegen lässt sich Open-Source-Software relativ einfach portieren. Und Mac OS X kommt ja auch serienmäßig mit einer ganzen Reihe von Open-Source-Geschichten. Was weiß ich, Samba für das Windows-Sharing und andere Sachen.
Ja, das geht bei kleinen Textmode, Programmlos, Curls, SIP.
Alles, was man so auf der Kommandozeile vorfindet, ganz klar. Das ist halt so UNIX, wie man das eben kennt.
Deshalb ist es auch so belebt, würde ich jetzt mal sagen.
Das spielt sicherlich eine große Rolle. Also so ein System, das irgendwie funktioniert, aber dann trotzdem UNIX...
Man hat eine Bash und fühlt sich zu Hause.
Genau. Das ist in Hacker-Kreisen auf jeden Fall ein echtes Argument. Ich kann mich noch eine Zeit erinnern, da gab es im CCC nur einen, der einen Macintosh hatte. Das war ich. Mittlerweile sieht das schon ein bisschen anders aus. Ich muss ehrlich sein, ich weiß nicht, ob ich wirklich der Einzige war, aber ich war auf jeden Fall einer von sehr wenigen, die das System überhaupt ernst genommen haben. Da habe ich dann auch Glück gehabt, weil das Upgrade auf Mac OS X zukunftsträchtig nicht das Apple es noch lange gemacht hätte mit dem alten System. Das war eine lange Zeit eine totale Katastrophe und die eigenen Entwicklungen bei Apple, Stichwort Copland, also der Versuch, aus dem Mac OS 9 etwas halbwegs modernes zu machen. Das waren alles sehr halbherzige Schritte und das ist ihnen dann auch kräftig im Hals stecken geblieben, was ja dann letzten Endes zum Kauf von Next geführt hat.
Soweit ich weiß, wollten sie sogar richtig von vorne anfangen. Sie wollten nicht mehr so aus dem Alten was rausholen, sondern sie wollten direkt von vorne anfangen und haben sich aber trotzdem irgendwo verrannt, aber das ist natürlich jetzt nicht...
Es hatte alles nicht mehr Hand und Fuß bei Apple. Man hat auch gemerkt, dass ihnen der Steve Jobs fehlt. Dann haben sie halt einfach gesagt, naja, dann kaufen wir doch das OS, wo der Steve Jobs mit eingebaut ist. Dann funktioniert das vielleicht wieder. Und schwuppsdiwupps hatten sie einen neuen Chef. Okay, dieses Mach, was ist denn da jetzt so besonders dran? Ich meine, warum nimmt man Mach und warum nimmt man nicht einfach doch nur das BSD? Warum macht man sich die Mühe und schneidet einen Teil aus einem funktionierenden Betriebssystem heraus und verwendet eben Mach? Warum nicht einfach das so nehmen, wie UNIX ist?
Zum Beispiel den Vorteil dieser Mach-Messages, die Interprocess-Communication, die wunderschön funktioniert.
Wie funktioniert das? Also ich meine, was ist das genau?
Das ist einfach generell Interprocess-Communication oder Mach-Messaging.
Ja gut, also Interprocess-Communication ist schnell gesagt, da geht es halt einfach, Programme wollen miteinander reden, sie haben immer alles Mögliche an Bedarf, da gibt es ja auch im normalen UNIX auch solche Hooks, also das ist jetzt nichts besonderes von Mach, sondern jedes Betriebssystem hat irgendeine Form von Interprocess-Communication, weil sonst würde da einfach nicht viel stattfinden. Nur, Mach basiert es eben auf diesem Konzept der Messages.
Was steckt dahinter? Genau, unsere Mach-Message funktioniert eigentlich, also die Mach-Message selbst zu bauen, ist relativ kompliziert und dafür gibt es den MIG, diesen Mach Interface Generator, der in einem Adressraum suggeriert, bzw. den Quotern tatsächlich baut, eine Funktion, die eigentlich in einem anderen Adressraum liegt. Das heißt, eine Funktion will eine andere aufrufen, die in einem anderen Adressraum liegt. Diese Funktion wird dann im gleichen Adressraum von diesem Mach Interface Generator generiert. Er denkt also, er hat sie im Adressraum, die Funktion ruft sie auf, dann werden aber die Adress-Spaces geswitcht. Im anderen ist die Funktion, das ist eine Message rübergesendet worden, über den Kernel. Dort wird die Funktion dann aufgerufen und natürlich dann der Output auf dem gleichen Weg wieder zurückgeschickt.
Das heißt, die Abstraktion des Verschicken einer Nachricht ist etwas, was man im Programm selber so gar nicht sieht?
Das sieht man gar nicht, nein.
Aber zu welchem Zeitpunkt benutz ich denn diesen Generator? Also zu welchem Zeitpunkt benutz ich denn dieses Interface?
Beim Programmieren.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ich weiß, ich möchte jetzt mit einem anderen Prozess kommunizieren...
Richtig, man merkt es aber gar nicht.
Lass ich mir vom System sozusagen da einen Stub generieren, den ich einfach benutze wie eine normale Funktion und ich rufe eine andere Funktion in einem anderen Programm auf. Genau. Aber intern ist es ein Messagesystem?
Genau, es ist ein getarntes Messaging-System.
Und was ist der Vorteil davon, dass es irgendwie asynchron ablaufen kann?
Es kann asynchron ablaufen. Es können die Nachrichten der Reihe nach aufgereiht werden und der Reihe nach wieder abgerufen werden. Das ist ein Vorteil.
Auch im Hinblick darauf, dass ja Mach von vornherein multistrettet ist. Ja, genau. Das heißt, diese Gleichzeitigkeit in der Kommunikation wird an der Stelle auch gleich unterstützt. Und es geht aber auch übers Netz?
Es geht theoretisch auch übers Netz, aber da weiß ich nicht genau, wie das dann funktionieren soll oder was dann die speziellen...
Okay, lassen wir das raus. Gibt es noch weitere bemerkenswerte Eigenschaften von Mach, die dir jetzt an der Stelle noch aufgefallen sind, die wichtig sein könnten, zu erklären, warum man jetzt Mach nimmt und nicht das normale UNIX?
Das normale UNIX?
Also ich meine, eine Sache haben wir im Prinzip schon angesprochen. Das ist halt die Sache mit dem Multistreading. Mach ist ja von vornherein darauf ausgelegt gewesen. Der Mach-Task besteht aus mehreren Threads.
Ja, genau.
Das heißt, der Mach-Thread ist sozusagen der eigentliche Execution Unit. Also wenn das, was irgendwie läuft, das, was sozusagen das ausführende Programm ist, ist ein Thread, und die sind wiederum gruppiert zu diesem Task. Richtig?
Ich würde es andersrum sagen. Also ich würde sagen, zum Beispiel... Ich sag's mal andersrum, genau. Zum Beispiel Open Office ist ein Task, und alles, was darin geschieht, das sind die einzelnen Threads.
Dann reden wir von der gleichen Sache. Das meinte ich ja. Auf Prozessor-Ebene ist halt das, was läuft, ist das Thread, und es ist halt gruppiert zu einem Task, und das heißt unter UNIX ein Prozess.
Gut, du hast nur gemeint, mit Programm wäre der Thread.
Genau, wir reden von derselben Sache. Aber das ist ja genau der Punkt bei dieser ganzen Geschichte. Man kommt schnell durcheinander. Und genau diese Sachen, die einen immer durcheinander bringen, führen auch dazu, dass viele Leute die Begriffe durcheinander webeln. Und dass halt zum Beispiel diese Aussage kommt, aha, alles klar, da ist ja jetzt Mach, also ist ja Mac OS X ein Mikrokernel. Aber das ist nicht richtig.
Das ist nicht richtig. Die anderen, also die BSD-Parts, die laufen ganz genauso im Kernel-Mode. Und im Endeffekt ist es ein monolithische Kern.
Der nur an das Internen strukturiert ist, weil er sich eben einen Kern aus dem einen Projekt geholt hat und ein OS-Environment aus dem anderen Projekt geholt hat und das eben zusammengebracht hat. Aber du hast ja eingangs schon erwähnt, es gibt ja noch ein anderes, drittes, wichtiges Standbein, was nochmal eine eigene Abstraktion darstellt in dem gesamten Kernel. Das ist das Treiberunwesen.
Ja genau, das Treiberunwesen. Das IO-Kit, das ist eine ganz schöne Lösung. Da habe ich in meinem Vortrag schon erwähnt, wie es normalerweise gemacht wird, dass man einfach code, man guckt, welcher Treiber könnte wohl am besten passen und verändert dann das entsprechende. Und hier ist es eben so gemacht, es gibt sogenannte Base Class Drivers, zum Beispiel ein CD-ROM-Treiber. Das wäre jetzt eine Base Class. Es gibt ein Base Class Treiber und es gibt ein spezielles CD-ROM-Laufwerk, das dann gewisse Änderungen verlangt. Und in dem Fall wird die Base Class genommen und es werden nur die Änderungen markiert.
Anders ausgedrückt, es ist objektorientiert und es unterstützt Vererbung. Das heißt, man muss nicht sämtliche Funktionalität immer wieder neu erfinden, wenn man ein neues Gerät hat. Sondern man dockt explizit auf der Basis von Vererbung an.
Und es ist eben nicht alles doppelt und dreifach. Und wenn der Base Class Treiber verändert wird, muss sich der individuelle Programmierer, der den speziellen Treiber geschrieben hat, nicht darum kümmern, was passiert da oben.
Sondern man erbt automatisch die neue Funktionalität und die Bugfixes auch natürlich mit rein, was die Entwicklung leichter macht. Das heißt, wenn ich ein, was weiß ich, nennen wir mal ein einfaches Beispiel, keine Ahnung, USB Serial Device. Also USB ist schon mal das eine. Dann gibt es halt so die Besonderheit von, ich bin ein serielles Device. Das heißt, ich verhalte mich irgendwie eigentlich wie so eine serielle Schnittstelle, nur das Ganze läuft eben über USB. Und darauf gibt es dann eine spezielle Funktionalität. Was weiß ich, so ein GPS-Modul zum Beispiel. Vielleicht ein ganz gutes Beispiel, die Dinger klemmt dann irgendwie über USB ran, verhalten sich irgendwie wie seriell. Und das ist ja auch das, wie meistens solche Dinge dann ins Betriebssystem integriert werden. Das heißt, das Programm muss dieses GPS-Modul ansprechen, als wäre es so ein serielles Teil. Aber eigentlich könnte man auch hergehen und sagen, ich mache jetzt explizit einen GPS-Treiber. Und der erbt dann einfach von dem USB-seriell, der wiederum von dem USB-Grundtreiber erbt, sodass man sich dann letzten Endes wirklich nur um die oberste Schicht kümmern muss, nämlich die eigentliche Kommunikation mit dem GPS-Ding. Das ist natürlich jetzt kein besonders komplexes System, weil die Dinger die ganze Zeit einfach nur was ausmachen. Aber ich denke, das zeigt ganz gut, welche Abstraktion hier gemeint ist.
Es ist einfach schön für den Benutzer und auch schön für den Programmierer, der sich jetzt nicht darum kümmern muss, wenn permanent alles geändert wird. Wenn der Base-Class-Driver nicht mehr kompatibel wäre zu dem anderen, dann ist es relativ schwer, einen Driver zu schreiben, der dann auch noch einen längeren Bestand hat. Ja, richtig.
Wobei Programmierung ist ja ganz interessant. Das IO-Kit ist ja anders, als wenn man Anwendungsentwicklung macht bei Mac OS X. Da nimmt man dann halt Objective-C, eine spezielle Objektvariante der C-Programmiersprache. Beim IO-Kit wird hartes C++ programmiert, beziehungsweise eine Sonderform, das sogenannte Embedded C++. Was im Wesentlichen C++ ist, minus ein paar Features, die grundsätzlich ausgeschlossen sind, wobei ich jetzt auch nicht ganz genau weiß, welche Features sind, aber es geht halt, also Templates zum Beispiel, können da nicht verwendet werden und ein paar andere Sachen, aber das ist halt an der Stelle der Ansatz. Auch ganz interessant zu sehen, weil der Rest ist ja in C programmiert, oder? Das heißt, der ganze, also mach, klar, BSD sowieso, ist alles C, IO-Kit ist C++, und Programme schreibt man in Objective-C. Na super, schön bunte Geschichte. Du bist ja in deinem Vortrag auch noch auf was anderes eingegangen, nämlich so die Eigenschaft des Macs eigentlich selber, insbesondere der Intel Macs, weil sich ja ein Mac von einem PC auch unterscheidet schon von Anfang an beim BIOS. Genau. Also ich sage jetzt schon BIOS, das ist im Prinzip die falsche Aussage, weil BIOS hat er ja nicht. Richtig, ja.
Das ist EFI.
EFI BIOS, also die neue Firmware-Software von Intel. Nach langer, langer Zeit hat man sich dann mal durchgerungen, das vielleicht dann doch mal neu zu machen. Auf dem Mac gab es ja eigentlich schon immer moderne Firmware, in Anführungsstrichen. Also man hat früher, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das einen Namen gehabt hat, war auf jeden Fall das System ja schon immer in der Lage, Karten, die man reinsteckt, als solche auch zu erkennen. So, zu Zeiten auf dem PC, wo dann irgendwelcher Code immer so im IO. Bereich, so wie so ein Blinder mit seinem Taststock, so irgendwie so tap, tap, tap, was könnte denn da sein? So, ah, wenn ich hier irgendwie was reinschreibe, dann sieht das mal so aus wie eine serielle Schnittstelle und so. So lief das ja echt lange Zeit. Weil es ging nie anders, weil es gab keinen definierten Modus, dass Karten, die man jetzt in den Rechner reingesteckt hat, gesagt haben, hallo, ich bin's, deine neue Karte und ich heiße, mein Hersteller ist lalala und irgendwie mein Adressbereich ist und Interrupts brauche ich übrigens auch noch. Das muss man irgendwie alles selber reinfinden. Das hat sich über die Zeit ein bisschen verbessert, insbesondere durch PCI. Das heißt, PCI hat auch einem PC schon so ein bisschen mehr Automatik gebracht. Das war bei Mac ein schlimmer Standard. Und Apple ist ja dann mit Sun in ein Boot gehüpft und hat die Open-Firmware benutzt, was im Wesentlichen so ein...
Für Power-PC.
Genau, für Power-PC. Und dann hat das eben bei ihren Spark-Maschinen benutzt. Dort war es halt so, dass die Karten oder sämtlichen Systemkomponenten, die irgendwie am Bus waren, dann eben so Force-Code bereitstellen konnten, sodass man auch an der Stelle Dinge automatisieren konnte. Und vor allem, dass eben das System sich hier selber gemeldet hat. Und vor allem, dass das Booting, sagen wir mal, so ein definierter Prozess war. Wie läuft denn das jetzt mit dem Intel EFI?
Ja, das Schöne am EFI ist in erster Linie schon mal, dass der die Partitionstabelle erkennt. Und er kann auch das Fallsystem darin lesen. Das ist schon mal ein Faktor. Das BIOS kann das nicht. Das BIOS liest nur den Masterboot-Record und springt dorthin. Und dann ist der Masterboot-Record auf sich allein gestellt.
Das heißt, ein starrer PC mit BIOS kennt eigentlich seine Partitionen gar nicht?
Nein.
Der weiß überhaupt nicht, was auf der Platte ist. Das heißt, wenn man zwei oder drei Betriebssysteme installiert hat, dann ist der Computer selbst nicht in der Lage, das zu erkennen?
Richtig. Und das ist ja auch, soweit ich weiß, der Grund, weshalb man keinen Spaß mehr damit hat, wenn man Linux und Windows versucht, auf einer Platte zu installieren. Es ist immer ein bisschen ein Gefrickel.
Das heißt, bei EFI ist das geändert worden und das BIOS, also die Firmware des Computers, hat Kenntnis darüber, wie die Festplatte aufgeteilt ist und kann sozusagen selber, ohne dass irgendein Code von irgendwo geladen werden muss, erkennen, oh, alles klar, die Platte besteht aus 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 Teilen und das ist jetzt derjenige, von dem derzeit mal gebootet werden soll, dann mache ich das jetzt auch.
Genau, dann kannst du das Kernel-Cache laden, vorausgesetzt, dass dir keine zusätzliche Hardware dazugekommen ist, wenn alles unverändert ist.
Ich kann das Kernel-Cache laden, was heißt das? Also wir reden jetzt wieder von Mac OS X.
Ja, der Kernel-Cache wird geladen.
Also das EFI weiß ja nie, was lädt, oder? Also ich meine, das guckt in die Partition und dann ist da irgendwas zum Laden.
Genau.
Und das wird dann geladen.
Und das wird geladen, genau.
Okay, das heißt jetzt sind wir sozusagen schon vom Rechner wieder ins Betriebssystem gesprochen.
Richtig, das ist schon der Schritt erledigt.
Okay, was macht der Mac OS X Kernel, wenn er bootet?
Was er rein macht.
Ja, also jetzt hast du das mit dem Cache untersprochen. Der macht es, genau. Das ist ja eine Funktionalität von Mac OS X, nicht von EFI.
Richtig, der bootet im Endeffekt, der lädt alle Treiber, die vorher schon, die beim letzten.
Na sagen wir doch mal, wir schalten diese Büchse das allererste Mal ein nach dem Installieren.
Nach dem Installieren? Dann guckt er bei jeder Kext, die er hätte.
Was ist das?
Kext ist eine Kernel-Extension. Das kann ein Driver sein, das kann ein Netzwerk-Driver sein, das kann ein Fallsystem-Driver sein, was auch immer.
Also irgendein Stück Code, der den Kernel um Funktionalität erweitert.
Genau.
Aber auch das System selber besteht schon aus solchen Kext?
Besteht nicht, sind Teil davon. Und er guckt für jede Kext, ist die Hardware da, ja oder nein? Nein, ist sie da, wird die Kext geladen. Und nächste. Und so weiter. Und das wird eben unglaublich beschleunigt, dadurch, dass er merkt sich beim Shutdown, merkt es sich, welche Kext waren geladen. Und beim nächsten, wenn sich nichts geändert hat, ist es sofort wieder alles da.
Ja gut, aber wenn sich was geändert hat, dann muss er ja auch erstmal gucken, ob sich was geändert hat.
Dann dauert es wieder.
Was heißt das? Das heißt, wenn ich zum Beispiel eine neue Karte in meinen Rechner gesteckt habe?
Richtig, zum Beispiel.
Okay, aber beim Laptop passiert das ja nicht so häufig. Aber das ist jetzt nicht, wenn ich...
Das passiert nicht. Ich habe es einmal erlebt und ich weiß gerade gar nicht, was ich da gemacht habe. Ich habe es einmal erlebt und dann zeigt er es auch an.
Was hast du erlebt?
Dass er nach allen, dass er alle Kekse durchgeht. Einmal erlebt. Was heißt das?
Wie kann man denn das erleben?
Er schreibt hin, dass sich die Hardware geändert hat seit dem letzten Start und dann dauert es ein paar Minuten.
Er schreibt das hin?
Er schreibt das hin.
Jetzt muss man, glaube ich, eine magische Tastaturkombination erklären, die wahrscheinlich die Mac-User schon mal ausprobiert haben. Ich weiß sie. Ich weiß sie.
Ich muss jedes Mal entweder überlegen, nachschauen oder ausprobieren. Ich probiere es aus. Apfel-V.
Apfel-V darf man jetzt nicht mehr sagen. Es heißt ja jetzt Command, weil der Apfel von der Tastatur verschwunden ist. Also Blumenkohl-Propeller-Taste-V. Wer das beim Einschalten des Rechners gedrückt hält, also in dem Moment, wo man wirklich so, jetzt geht es los, wenn man dann sofort auf Apfel-V bleibt, dann kommt nämlich auch ein Macintosh so hoch, wie man das von UNIX-Computern eigentlich gewohnt ist. Also mit viel schwarz-weiß Text, mit diesem ganzen Lalalala, was jetzt gerade geladen wird, welcher Treiber gerade geladen wird usw. Die Dämonen, bis er dann eben in diesen Login-Screen geht. Auch dann wird es wieder grafisch. Aber das, was vorher nur so drehendes Rädchen und Apfel anzeigen ist, das kann man sich halt dadurch sparen.
Aber was ich gemeint habe, mit ich habe es erlebt. Ich habe es als ganz normaler User erlebt. Er schreibt es tatsächlich auch explizit beim Booten. Wenn man das Rädchen sieht, zeigt einem dann an, dass sich die Halbe geändert hat. Das meinte ich.
Das habe ich schon lange nicht mehr gesehen, weil ich habe nämlich mein Rechner immer in diesem coolen Schwarz-Weiß-Modus. Es gibt so ein Tool. Ich muss gleich mal gucken, wie heißt denn das Teil? Na, ich penne. Ich glaube, es heißt ONIX. Das ist so ein kleines Tool, mit dem man sich allerlei Settings einstellen kann, auch was Firmware betrifft. Da kann man nämlich reinstellen, bitte immer sofort im Verbose-Modus hochkommen. Ich mache das nur zum Posen. Ich will aber wissen, wo die Büchse ihre Zeit verbringt, wenn es dann doch dennoch dauert mit dem booten. Ja, man bootet selten. Das stimmt. Man bootet selten mit dem Mac. Aber wenn man mal bootet und man will alles sehen, dann dann. Und auch beim Shutdown, dann sieht man ganz genau, was passiert. Das ist manchmal ganz hilfreich, weil man sich eine blöde Software eingefangen hat, die ein paar Touren nicht beenden will. Da sieht man dann meistens, wer der Bösewicht ist. Oder zumindest sieht man, wo viel Zeit verbraucht wird. Nach dem Motto, ja, die Mentralala will jetzt irgendwie einfach mal nicht enden, ich kille den mal. Da sind natürlich so Sachen, die ein Mac OS X in seiner grafischen Ausprägung, also in seinem normalen Erscheinungsbild, so natürlich kein Benutzer zumuten möchte. Aber mit APFEL-V wird alles super. Das heißt, wir wissen jetzt, woraus besteht das Betriebssystem. Das hatten wir schon. Und wir wissen jetzt auch, wie es bootet. Und es gibt jetzt also diesen Kernel-Cache, der im Wesentlichen dafür sorgt, dass das Ding ab dem zweiten Mal, wenn er seine Hardware kennt, schneller hochkommt. Und er kommt schnell hoch. Ich finde, so ein Mac OS X ist echt fix im Booten. Eine weitere Eigenschaft, die ja bemerkenswert ist und die du auch in deinem Vortrag rausgeführt ist, ist die Sache, wie Macintosh damit der Tatsache umgeht, dass es ja sehr viele unterschiedliche Architektur gibt. Es gibt ja derzeit im Wesentlichen vier unterschiedliche Architekturen, die man auseinanderhalten muss.
Ja, würde ich vier sagen. Also 32-Bit, 34-Bit und dann PowerPC und dann...
34-Bit? 32, 64-Bit, also es gibt ja G4, G5, G5 ist dann 64-Bit, also kann 64-Bit sein. ja, Intel kann auch 32-Bit oder 64-Bit sein. Wenn wir von 64-Bit reden, dann meinen wir Adressraum. Richtig?
Genau, ansprechbarer.
64-Bit kann ja so einiges sein. Intern gibt es auch Register, die 64-Bit sind und so weiter, aber wenn man von 64-Bit redet, meint man vor allem, wie viel Speicher kann direkt adressiert werden. Also wie lang sind die Adressen, mit denen die Programme bzw. der Kernel auch arbeiten? Jetzt aber die Frage, was ist denn jetzt 64-Bit und was ist 32-Bit bei Mac?
Also der Kernel ist definitiv nicht 64-Bit. Der Kernel ist 32-Bit. Und...
Das heißt, der Kernel selbst kann tatsächlich für sich genommen nur 4 GB Speicheradressen.
Genau, richtig.
Aber es reicht ja eigentlich auch.
Das reicht schon.
Ich meine, der Kernel braucht ja auch nicht mehr. Wäre ja noch schöner, wenn er mehr als 4 GB RAM fressen würde. Na gut, er kann...
Es ist eigentlich nur nicht schön, er kann es nicht ansprechen. Möglicherweise... Ja, es ist nicht so schön, weil er das nicht direkt ansprechen kann, weil es immer das nette Switcher gibt oben, der oben im Address-Space immer gemapt ist. Und der dann switcht zur 34-Bit-Applikation, dann switcht er wieder zurück zum Kernel. Also das ist... Weil es gibt den... Das wird ja immer komplett geswitched.
Aber die Programme können ja 64-Bit sein.
Die können sein, ja.
32-Bit und 64-Bit, die laufen ja auch gleichzeitig. Aber der Kernel selber... Also ich meine, man muss ja sowieso immer hin und her switchen zwischen dem Programm und dem Korn. Von daher braucht er ja eigentlich gar keinen 64-Bit.
Richtig.
Also ich meine, wenn er 64-Bit brauchen würde, würde das ja heißen, er bräuchte mehr als 4 GB RAM. Und das würde ich ja nicht so gut finden, wenn mein Betriebssystem so viel RAM wegnimmt, oder? Ist das fürs Buffer-Win?
Naja, das ist ja eigentlich egal.
Er kann das auch nicht als Buffer-Cache benutzen, sozusagen.
Es ist ja völlig egal. Er hat einmal den ganzen Adressraum, damit geswitched hat er wieder die Applikation den ganzen. Der Kernel nimmt keinem was weg.
Das stimmt. Aber er kann auch nicht selber mehr als 4 GB benutzen, für Buffering zum Beispiel, für Fallsystems, Speicher.
Ich meine, es muss es sein.
Aber das ist ja noch nicht... Meinst du, dass das eine Limitierung derzeit tatsächlich im Kernel darstellt, dass sie es nicht könnten? Oder ist es nur so, dass sie es nicht tun?
Dass sie nicht 64bit machen?
Ja. Also ich meine, vielleicht ist es ja auch einfach so, dass sie der Meinung sind, wozu sollen wir jetzt im Kernel mehr als vier Gigabyte benutzen?
Ich könnte es mir theoretisch vorstellen. Ich könnte mir aber auch vorstellen, dass es früh oder später kommt.
Genau. Weil ich meine, was sollte sie davon abhalten, 460bit zu machen, weil...
Ja, es wäre theoretisch logisch, aber... Möglicherweise, ich weiß es nicht.
Okay, aber Tatsache ist, dass der... Dass der Mac Programme laufen lassen kann im 64bit Modus. Und zwar gleichzeitig. Es gibt nicht, wie jetzt bei Vista zum Beispiel, verschiedene Versionen des Betriebssystems, mal 64bit, mal 32bit, sondern es gibt nur eine einzige Version, die alles laufen lassen kann.
Es gibt einen Kernel-Image.
Genau. Diese Sache mit dem RAM und diesem Hin- und Herswichen, ich glaube, das habe ich auch nicht so ganz verstanden bei dem Vortrag. Kannst du das noch mal zusammenbringen? Weil da gibt es ja auch einen entscheidenden Unterschied zu Linux und anderen Betriebssystemen und wie der Mac mit dem RAM umgeht.
Ja...
Diese 3.1, 4.4-Geschwindigkeit?
Genau, richtig, richtig. Da, wo ich auch in meinem Vortrag auf dem Folien steht, steht Switch, das heißt eigentlich Split. Es ist 3.1 Split bei Linux zum Beispiel. Der Kernel hat dann eben 1 GB und User-Land-Application hätte dann eben 3 GB.
Also wovon reden wir?
Wir reden vom Adressraum.
Okay, wir reden vom Adressraum und der Computer, wir gehen jetzt mal von einem Computer aus, der hat 4 GB RAM. Physikalisch tatsächlich reingesteckt, ist ja mittlerweile auch nicht mehr so ungewöhnlich, und 4 GB RAM ist die Menge an Speicher, die man mit einem 32-Bit-Pointer, also einem Zeiger, der 2 hoch 32 ist die Zahl, also 32-Bit-Wert, direkt adressieren und damit ansprechen kann. So, und was ist jetzt mit diesen 4 GB? Was kann davon verwendet werden? Von wem?
Also ein Teil, ein GB, ist jetzt immer konstant für den Kernel reserviert, sozusagen bei Linux. Und der Rest eben für die Applikationen.
Es sei denn, man hat einen 64-Bit-Linux, dann gilt das natürlich nicht mehr.
Dann gilt es nicht mehr, richtig.
Aber auf ein 32-Bit-System ist sozusagen das GB auch weg. Das heißt, das kann von dem Programm nicht genutzt werden.
Und das ist auch gleich der Vorteil von Mac. Jede Applikation hat 4 GB zur Verfügung. Und der Kernel könnte es dann eben auch haben. Und es wird jedes Mal Address-Space geswitcht.
Vollständig.
Vollständig, genau. Das heißt, die Applikation hat immer das Gefühl, sie hätte sämtliche 4 GB Adressraum zur Verfügung.
Hat sie aber natürlich. Also sie hat den Adressraum, aber sie hat wirklich 4 GB wirklich jetzt selber zur Verfügung, weil der Kernel braucht ja auch nochmal ein bisschen Platz. Aber es gibt in dem Sinne keine Limitierung. Okay, dann kann man jetzt sich darüber streiten, ob ein Programm so sehr viel davon hat, 4 GB auch wirklich vollständig zu adressieren. Aber, was weiß ich, vielleicht mag das ja für das eine oder andere Programm auch relevant sein. Weil es gibt durchaus Programme, die natürlich viel speichern. Aber da kann man auch sagen, okay, dann kann man auch gleich auf 64-Bit gehen.
Oder so.
Ja, aber das ist ja wiederum das Schöne am Mac. Da geht das auch. Das heißt, das ist dieses 3.1 versus 4.4. Das heißt, beim Macintosh hat jedes Programm vollen 4 GB Adressraum zur Verfügung im 32-Bit-Modus. Und im 64-Bit-Modus entsprechend mehr. Wahrscheinlich. Du hast ja deine Lieblingsfeatures dann am Schluss auch nochmal in den Fokus gerückt.
Ja.
Fand ich ganz interessant. Noch mal so eine persönliche Meinung damit reinzubringen. Kannst du vielleicht nochmal so die wichtigsten, die dir jetzt so gleich einfallen, auch nochmal zum Besten geben?
Ja, ich mag den Mac Message Interface Generator, mag ich ganz gern, den Mic. Das habe ich aber vorhin jetzt gerade schon ausgeführt. Ich kann das vorhin nicht mehr ausführen. Und dann diese Four Way Universal Binaries, die finde ich sehr hübsch. Das sind, dass in jedem Programm quasi Code enthalten ist für sämtliche vier Architekturen.
Stimmt. Der Mac verwendet ja ein anderes Binary-Format, als es jetzt bei Linus üblich ist. Da ist es dieses 11-Format. Bei Mac heißt es?
Mac Mac O, natürlich.
Oder auch Macho? Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich so gedacht war, das so auszusprechen, aber das Mac-Object-Format schreibt sich zumindest. Okay, die Macho-Software. Und das deckt im Prinzip genau diese Architekturen, von denen wir vorhin geredet haben, im Prinzip ab. Wir haben PowerPC, Intel und Intel, und beides jeweils in 32-Bit und 64-Bit. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt ein Programm hat, was auf allen Plattformen laufen soll, dann kann man ein Binary erzeugen. Wir reden jetzt auch wirklich von einer einzigen physikalischen Datei im Dateisystem, in der der Code für alle Architekturen mit drin ist. Das heißt, egal, wo man das Ding startet, jedes OS findet den Code, den es am liebsten ausfindet. Wie entscheidet er dann, ob er eine 64-Bit-Version oder eine 32-Bit-Version startet, wenn das System beides. Wenn ich jetzt einen 64-Bit-Computer habe und es liegt eine 64-Bit-Version vor, dann nimmt er die auch. Okay, gut, weil die läuft ja dann auch unter Umständen noch ein bisschen fixer und optimaler, stimmt.
Ja, es nimmt schon die Version.
Immer das dickste.
Ich denke, das entsprechende.
Ja gut, der Kernel haben wir ja gerade festgestellt, ist ja selber nicht 64-Bit. Das heißt, die Programme haben ja sozusagen die Wahl, das eine oder das andere zu sein. Aber wenn halt eine 64-Bit-Version vorliegt und die könnte ausgeführt werden, dann wird die auch bevorzugt genommen. Noch so ein Lieblingsfeature?
Ach, das ändert sich auch immer mal wieder. Was habe ich denn noch erwähnt? Ach, ich fand auch das Detrace, finde ich ganz hübsch. Das ist nur ein kleines, nettes Feature am Rande. Detrace schreibt zur Laufzeit Kernel-Code neu, dass man extra statistische Daten bekommt. Das ist ganz interessant für Debugging. Und nimmt den Code auch wieder raus. Normalerweise muss man das ja so machen, dass man ein komplett neues Kernel-Image kompiliert, mit dann Code drin für statistische Daten, zur Erhebung von statistischen Daten.
Also wenn man jetzt den Kernel selber, also wenn man jetzt den Treiber schreibt zum Beispiel.
Oder zum Beispiel völlig irrelevantes Statistik, wie oft wird denn jetzt 64-Bit-Code ausgeführt, zum Beispiel. Wäre nur ein Beispiel dafür, was man so an statistischen Daten erheben könnte. Und das funktioniert mit Detrace eben zur Laufzeit. Und man braucht kein extra Kernel-Image mit einem dicken Code verwenden, sondern kann das zur Laufzeit den Code neu reinschreiben und wieder rausnehmen.
Aber das ist ja auch ein Feature, was dem Programm zur Verfügung steht. Man muss keine debuggigen Versionen mehr von seinem Programm erzeugen. Sondern das macht einem das Detrace-Subsystem von Mac OS X von sich aus transparent. Ist da ein Einblick, was da jetzt wirkt, um das zu ermöglichen?
Wie das genau funktioniert, das weiß ich nicht.
Wir haben keine Ahnung. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express und wir haben keine Ahnung. Okay, mal gucken. Vielleicht kann ich das ja im nächsten Podcast noch nachtragen.
Ich weiß nicht inwiefern, dass die Öffentlichkeit zugänglich ist.
Ich gucke nochmal, was deine Lieblingssachen waren, wenn dir jetzt schon selber nicht mehr einfallen. Du findest es awesome, hast du geschrieben. Ist dir das überhaupt bewusst, dass du das geschrieben hast?
Awesome?
Das ist mein Lieblingswort. Sehr amerikanisch, wenn ich das so sagen darf. Das ist ein schönes Wort. Ja.
Ein sehr amerikanisches Wort.
Ah ja, genau. Du fandest es auch noch toll, dass die ABI von den Kexts stable ist.
Gut, ja, das hatte ich ja schon erwähnt, dass es für Programmierer sehr angenehm ist.
Aber wir haben nur über die Object-Geschichte gemacht. Ich meine, die Geschichte ist ja die, Apple hat ja dieses Interface lange Zeit überhaupt nicht herausgegeben. Also es ist ja eigentlich erst seit Tiger, seit 10.04, gibt es überhaupt dieses Kernel-Interface. Also es gab es natürlich auch schon vorher, und es gab auch irgendwie schon Treiber, aber dass sich das jetzt nicht mehr ändert, das garantieren sie jetzt. Ich frage mich, wie lange sie das garantieren können. Was heißt schon stable? Weil es ja geier, ich meine, vielleicht kommen sie bei der nächsten Version schon wieder an und sagen, wir haben uns das nochmal überlegt, und es ist jetzt irgendwie alles nicht bunt genug.
Ja, es ist ein gewagtes Vorhaben, würde ich mal sagen.
Aber immerhin, ich meine, Treibersicherheit ist natürlich bei Betriebssystemen durchaus ein Thema. Man sieht das jetzt gerade bei Windows Vista, wo die Leute natürlich auch nicht gerade besonders glücklich sind, dass ihre Treiber dann es nicht in die nächste Generation des Betriebssystems geschafft haben. Und das ist natürlich auch für den Hersteller eigentlich Quatsch. Während so ein Update von 10.4 auf 10.5 schon sich extrem angenehm angefühlt hat. Wobei ich nicht behaupten kann, dass alle Treiber dann noch funktioniert haben. Also es ist schon möglich, wenn es wirklich schlecht programmiert ist, dann kann es dann auch brechen. Also es befreit einen nicht unbedingt davon, von schlechten Programmierern verfolgt zu werden. Ich sage nur Audio-Interfaces. Da habe ich schon mal droh geklagt. Ich tue es an dieser Stelle nochmal. Ja, wie auch immer. Jetzt denke ich, haben wir schon einen ganz guten Zusammenschnitt gebracht. Gibt es noch irgendwas, was wir dringend erwähnen müssten, was dir noch einfällt? Warum gibt es eigentlich kein Open-Darwin-Projekt mehr?
Ach ja, das ist, warum es das nicht mehr gibt. Ich denke, das ist ein Phänomen der Masse, die Interesse an Open Source hätte. Nämlich, dass die Masse der Mac-User da kein Interesse daran hat.
Oder Mac-Programmierer.
Der Mac-Programmierer. Ja, sag mal so, die Masse der Mac-User hat kein Interesse daran, zu programmieren.
Hm, aber es gibt ja eine ganze Menge Programmierer auf der Mac-Plattform.
Es gibt mittlerweile einen ganzen Haufen. Es gab dieses Open Darwin-Projekt ja auch.
Aber es gibt halt keine... Naja, ich hab da so ein paar Thesen an. Ich hab da auch tatsächlich vor, da mal jemanden, der bei dem Projekt mitgearbeitet hat, hier auch nochmal einzuladen. Tatsächlich hätte das eigentlich schon nix stattfinden sollen. Musste aber leider nochmal verschoben werden. Ich hoffe, dass ich das im Februar auch nachholen werde. Aber meine Vermutung, und die können wir ja dann neben anderem Podcast auch nochmal überprüfen, war so die, einerseits ist es wohl nicht so einfach, mit Apple da zusammenzuarbeiten. Also wenn man so in den Apfel ein bisschen reinhorcht, ich hab das auch schon mal getan, da kam so ein bisschen dieses Ding zurück, naja, es programmiert ja auch keiner was in diesem Kernel. Also es gibt einfach niemanden, der wirklich diesen Source Code nimmt und modifiziert. Und das, obwohl ja eigentlich die Lizenz mittlerweile frei ist.
Es wäre möglich, ja.
Es ist schon so. Aber ich glaube, einfach ein System, das einfach nicht garantiert alles frei liefert, weil eben auch diese Sachen mit Treibern und so weiter, und es gibt halt immer mal wieder was, was Apple dann vielleicht doch nicht veröffentlichen möchte, trifft einfach nicht auf so viel Gegenliebe in so einer Open Source-Gemeinde, wo man eben sagt, naja, wenn ich da schon mitarbeite, dann will ich auch irgendwie alle Features, dann möchte ich auch irgendwie alles bekommen. Warum soll ich mich jetzt hier einbringen mit einer Company, die unter Umständen dann sich im Kreis dreht und sagt, naja, alles klar, jetzt haben wir aber hier irgendwelche DRM oder sonst wie Zwänge an einer Stelle auszuleben, ja, da passt uns das jetzt einfach mal mit dem Open Source nicht mit rein. Durchaus vorstellbar.
Ja, und gut, es gibt einfach viel zu viele andere interessante Projekte für Open Source-Fans, dass sie sich dann mit einer doch einigermaßen geschlossenen Firma auseinandersetzen möchten. Und eben dann, wie gesagt, kein Feedback zu erhalten.
Man muss es mal abwarten, wie sich das entwickelt. Ich meine, es gibt auch Gegenbeispiele. Ich hatte jetzt gerade in der letzten Sendung mit einem KDE-Entwickler gesprochen. Da kam das auch nochmal zur Sprache im Bereich WebKit, was jetzt mit dem Kernel natürlich so erstmal nichts zu tun hat. Aber die Renderin Engine von Apple ist ja wiederum sehr erfolgreich und auch durchaus ein überlebensfähiges Community-Projekt gewesen, wo eben neue Committer auch mit reingenommen werden. Also Apple tatsächlich diese vollständig geschlossene wir haben, ja, nur wir haben Zugriff auf den Code aufgegeben hat und gesagt hat, okay, alles klar, wir akzeptieren jetzt auch Leute von außen, die an dem Projekt ganz konkret Code beitragen, weil wir eben sehen, das funktioniert auch und das ist auch für uns gut. Ich denke, an der Stelle hat Apple auch ein wenig gelernt und auch die Notwendigkeit gesehen, dass wenn sie tatsächlich jetzt über den Open-Source-Pfad auch selber Standard setzen wollen, das ist ja bei WebKit zum Beispiel ganz klar ihr Ding, dass sie eben diese Offenheit auch benötigen. Nur Kernel ist, glaube ich, doch schon noch eine andere Abteilung, weil das ja nun auch wirklich die Essenz ist für Apple. Also so ihr Dogma dieses wir machen die Hardware und wir passen die Software darauf an. Und das ist unser Kernvorteil. Also zumindest sieht es Apple ja selber so.
Das ist definitiv ein Vorteil. Es ist ja viel überschaubarer.
Genau, und da wollen sie natürlich auch die Kontrolle in der Hand halten. Und ich glaube, das geht nicht so richtig zusammen mit Open Source und freien Kontributoren. Was ein bisschen schade ist, weil es gibt immer wieder so ein paar Features, die ich ganz gerne hätte. Zum Beispiel, was ich unbedingt mal haben möchte, ist, dass diese blinke Lampe da vorne an meinem Laptop, die immer nur so ein bisschen Halbseiden vor sich hin pulsiert, wenn der Rechner geschwindet ist, die ist ja, wenn ich den Rechner benutze, nicht in Betrieb. Und ich möchte da ganz gerne mal ein Disc-Zugriffslampchen haben. Und irgendjemand hat das mal gehackt, das gab es mal. Und ich weiß nicht, ob es das noch gibt. Und wenn es das nicht gibt, dann möchte ich zumindest mal jemanden, der das hackt. Also falls irgendjemand von euch da draußen weiß, wie man das einschalten kann, ich hätte das gerne.
Das stimmt, das hätte ich auch gerne.
Du hättest es auch gerne. Okay, wir sind uns einig.
Das erhält das Licht in der Nacht in diesem schönen pulsierenden Schlafzimmer.
Genau, das ist sehr schön, wenn er schläft. Aber ich möchte auch ganz gerne, wenn er wach ist, dass er mal was tut. Okay, wir fangen schon an, albern rumzulabern. Ich sage danke, Lucy, für die Ausführung zu Mac OS X Kernel. Und ja, das war es auch schon wieder von Chaosradio. Eine knappe, prägnante Sendung für meine Maßstäbe, für unsere durchschnittlichen Sendezeiten hier. Aber das muss ja nichts heißen. Gut, dass wir das Thema jetzt mal abgewickelt haben. Wie schon angesagt, werden wir hier am Mac noch ein bisschen dranbleiben und noch mindestens eine weitere Sendung dazu produzieren. Lasst euch überraschen, wie immer. Ich bedanke mich fürs Zuhören und ich hoffe, ihr gibt wieder Feedback per E-Mail at chaosradio.ccc.de oder vielleicht noch toller im Blog, blog.chaosradio.ccc.de in dem Posting zu dieser Sendung, was es immer gibt. Und freue mich, mit euch darüber zu diskutieren. Dann könnt ihr die Sendung dann auch gleich verreißen. Neulich die C++-Sendung steht gerade schwer unter Feuer. Finde ich auch ganz super. Aber Pavel ist da auch schon mit dran, Feedback zu geben. Ja, das war's. Und ich sag Tschüss. Bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.